-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor
and comedian, you know,
from movies such as "Air,"
the "Rush Hour" films,
and "Friday."
He's currently on his
Chris Tucker The Legend
stand-up tour.
You can see him
at the Beacon Theatre
here in New York,
November 17th and 18th.
Tickets are available
at christucker.com.
Please welcome to the show
Chris Tucker, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I like -- I like that.
Can y'all come and bring me
out tomorrow night
at the Beacon Theatre?
And the next night?
-There you go.
They're great, right?
-They are awesome, man.
-You're great.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Man, I'm happy to be here, man.
-This is very --
I will say,
let me tell you something,
because you've earned the right
to call yourself a legend.
-Thank you, man.
-You have to have the confidence
to put it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, I thought people
was trying to say I was old.
You know, younger people say,
"Man, you a legend."
I'm like, "I ain't that old,
man. Wait a minute."
And then I kind of accepted it.
-Yeah, you got to --
When they give you "Legend,"
you got to wear "Legend."
-You just take it.
-You got to take it.
-Yeah.
-You're playing the Beacon.
I know you've
played there before.
It is a wonderful theater.
Are you excited?
-I'm excited, man, I'm excited.
Last time I played there,
Harry Belafonte --
Harry Belafonte came and saw me,
and he said,
"Chris, you need to sing more."
And that's what I do in my show.
I sing, I dance, I act,
I do it all.
I tell jokes, I do it all.
So it's like --
it's like a Broadway play, man.
-You must be exhausted
at the end of it.
-You know what? I am.
I am. It's like --
It's like, you know --
It's like a racecar driver.
Formula 1 driver, man.
When I'm out there, in my show,
it's like, the energy
is coming at me.
I'm giving it back to them.
So it's a lot of fun, man.
A lot of fun.
-That's fantastic.
I know your last --
your last hour was on Netflix.
-Yeah.
You talked --
You're very honest
about things
that have happened in your life.
You're honest about tax
problems, things like that.
Is that still
what people can expect?
That you are kind of laying it
out there?
-I talk about it all.
I talk about it all.
I finally paid they butt off.
They had me on the road.
I told them --
I was like Tony Montana.
I said, "Let me go out
on the road, okay?
I'll make a meal here,
a meal there.
I'll get you the money.
Okay, mang?"
[ Laughter ]
"Take it easy, okay?
You gonna have a heart attack,
man. Calm down."
-That's great. And the --
-I did what I could on the side,
but I stay loyal to you, man.
[ Laughter ]
-And the IRS
responded to that.
-They responded. It was the IRS
tour for a couple years.
[ Laughter ]
They're backstage,
waiting on their money.
I said, "Y'all a trip."
-Yeah.
Maybe they love the show, too.
-They did. They enjoyed it.
-Now, you were the youngest
of six growing up in Atlanta.
Do you feel like
being the youngest
gives you a head start
in comedy?
Because you just sort of,
like, grow up
and you've got
this older audience
that's already sort
of delighted by you?
-Oh, definitely, man.
You learn faster,
because you see --
you see your brothers
and sisters make mistakes,
and see my brothers
get a whupping.
I'm like, "What you do?
God, dawg.
Daddy tore your butt up."
[ Laughter ]
"I didn't take out the garbage.
I got to make sure I take it out
when it's my turn."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-What day the garbage man come?
On Tuesday?
I got to remember that.
Yeah, all types of stuff, man.
You learn, and then you
with their older friends.
So you got to --
Then you can't say nothing.
So you got to fight
your way into conversations.
-Do you remember
the early things
that you were doing for jokes?
-Oh, well, I hosted
a high school talent show.
I talked about stuff.
I don't remember.
I was just like a natural.
People would say I was funny,
and I'd be like,
"What you talking about?"
They would say I remind them
of Eddie Murphy in high school.
Then I hosted a talent show,
and I did it in,
you know, a stand-up form,
and I told my first school joke,
and I got a little laugh,
and I said, "Oh, I'mma do
this the rest of my life."
-Oh, I know, right?
-Best feeling in the world, man.
-That first little itch,
and you're like,
"I'm never giving this up."
-Yeah, yeah.
You've had some incredible --
Before you sort of
were leads in films,
you would just steal movies
with tiny little appearances.
Johnny Booze.
-Oh, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
"House Party 3," yeah.
-"House Party 3."
-Yeah.
-And Johnny Booze
kind of shows up,
does his thing, and gets out.
But a very --
a very memorable character.
How much of Johnny Booze --
be honest --
was based on this outfit?
-It was all of it.
Because when they gave me
the outfit, I said,
"Oh, God, he's a pimp
or something, so...
[ Laughter ]
"I'mma go ahead and do it."
And that came from stand-up,
you know, being ready.
Whatever they throw at you,
you get out there,
and you just do it.
And I only had like
three minutes
to make my -- my mark,
you know, on that scene.
So, yeah, the outfit helps.
-Then, of course, "Friday."
-"Friday," yeah. Yes.
Smokey.
-Smokey.
-Smokey. Yeah.
-Anybody -- Did anybody
making this movie
have any sense of how long
a tail it would have,
how people would just be
in love with it for years?
-Nobody knew. Nobody knew.
I remember me and Faizon Love,
who played Big Worm,
went and saw the movie.
But it wasn't no score,
no music.
And we was like,
"Man, this is terrible, man.
We got to find another job."
[ Laughter ]
We didn't know, but I knew
that I did what I --
You know, I was prepared,
I knew it was my shot.
You know, coming from
stand-up to acting,
I had to, you know,
calm stuff down.
From stand-up, you're broad,
and acting,
you got to get
into the character.
So I knew I got --
I got all that right.
And when they put the score
and the music together,
the director, Gary Gray, said,
"No, man, trust me, it's a hit.
It's a good movie."
And we was like,
"Oh, we'll see."
And then it just became
what it became, so it's great.
-Do people still yell things
from Smokey?
-Oh, "Smokey!"
They always yell, "Smokey!"
I'll be at church --
"Smokey!"
Like, "Come on, man."
[ Laughter ]
"Respect the Lord, man."
"What's wrong with you?"
-And then -- and then --
So, you know, again,
this is a two-hander,
and smaller movies,
where everybody's like,
"Oh, my --"
You know, I remember
"Jackie Brown," for example.
You're like, "Oh, my God.
Who's that guy?
That guy's great."
Stealing movies
with these little parts.
And then, of course,
"Rush Hour" happens.
-Yes.
-And this is another thing, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I was so excited, man,
because I knew that I could
put my comedy
with Jackie Chan's martial arts,
and it would be fantastic.
But it's the 25th anniversary
of the first "Rush Hour."
-Unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, man, it don't --
It seem a long time ago,
but Jackie
was so kind and so nice.
He would give me a gift
every day
on the first "Rush Hour" set.
He would send me over a gift,
a different gift.
I said, "Man, what is this?
Part of his culture?"
He's so nice.
Then I realized he's from China.
They make everything over there,
he's getting it for free anyway.
-Oh, that's very unfair.
-He wasn't paying for nothing.
-Oh, man.
He's looking out the window,
like, "Look at Chris Tucker.
He gonna go broke
trying to keep up with me."
[ Laughter ]
"We make Jordan 1's in Taiwan."
-Speaking of Jordans, I want
to talk to you about "Air,"
which you were fantastic in.
We're gonna be more
with Chris right after this.